[Music]
closing will be just smooth
bicep on the
bicep it
[Music]
drop into your
head did it be a man and get it there
you go
so just put that up to measure and feel
don't
then come on come on you on once you go
once you go you have come in so that
he's not going to hit
you so if you're going slow you're
still going smooth okay
get it get
it next one that goes to the door okay
look high see how I look
high so to the gr boom same
measuring boom pull in the same
exact
leg SL
measure
boom this
I'm going to let the kick
pull the K kind of pull
go
[Music]
when you measure you're already
checking measure check if it goes up you
stay with there
okay there you
go that's it
you can
change then the other one
shove this over this way
there you got it
there
push bring it
up is
I just need to catch I don't care what
you
do especially when you driving you notet
to the arm catch it right there
sit but when you catch
it it's like this was here this
one catch
it you have to uh I have to like for
example I want to throw your head right
so if I throw your head I pass your head
the other arm so the same thing here and
I here like this I pass pass that okay
I'm doing that on purpose to catch it
not one oh see if
it's so you feeling drive that's when
you do
it and where is it
right right here here a little heavier
right here here it
bends right there
okay stay close
too your feel to drive fast
[Music]
right measuring boom and you drive right
that's throw so when I
throw I don't just throw up there's a
downward this get ready to feel it
here you see that helps your
drives throw down that's
it you step step your foot so think
about it here's my hand has to be
right okay so if my foot is way out here
be okay so my foot is right by your foot
so my
hand is right there
okay that foot a little more get weight
off that leg
SL yes don't too far the
so when when I get one leg the other leg
close yes that's it hold it okay
[Music]
yes
Bo and I'm going to go to this
neck see it
okay again you're trying for that under
hook and I go to this one then I find
this
Bice
okay one more time boom I just move
inside push
down so again you're
font don't contest so look if I'm if if
I'm at the wrong angle I can't get in
there so I have to move you see how I
move then I get in there and then same
thing I got to move to get the bicep
up nice and
smooth okay you what you're going to do
now nice and
smooth
[Music]
boom you need to get the find the in
here move to find the space other way
other way there is and then find that
space and get control get
control you're still barely getting
there get the back of my neck the back
of my head
have
slippery nice and
slippery boom
slippery Energy's happening right there
that's where reg go
slippery okay
slippery no you're fighting let him take
it boom go with the energy there it's
off in that's it get it down get my arm
away from G thumb on the on when you're
defending thumb when you're attacking no
thumb and you go get your head Ang
lower your Center eyes up B down drop
the
leg get it away from me get it away from
me
again slippery slippery
down you're there
down there not here I got to move out of
the way down
okay so there new one look here like
this I'm going do the same
sh
way that
tie okay I go here and see how I hug
right and then
it right
here right
there Pi it up that's it
[Music]
do I
have for
[Music]
one of those okay so the slip kick out
and
finalement and
then uh this one you got to change so we
do four of those and you're going to
turn around so I'm on the back here turn
so it's on the back of the KNE okay and
it's this one in
fin so notice that I'm kicking the back
of his knee so his knee can bend
okay right
here hands
up
fin okay let's try
this
my
foot
again
okay I came in boom I drive he'll drive
back he want stop backwards okay when
you feel that
energy hold you
do
the I'm doing the
movement with my
arm I'm here I was going for this and I
just use my arm don't M so much energy
I'm just going here
okay I'm not going here I'm trying for
that he drive
back very
simple drive drive drive to get him to
do that
yeah the
arm drive drive drive don't punch you
you don't occupy your spiral
displacement I'll punch you do you
understand there you go boom drop Dr you
feel
that time don't with
P Bo smooth that's what you feel too
late I'll do it like I'm smooth dry
that's all I'm doing
right got it I'll do it
again here
D you go nice and
smooth there it is yes
smooth there it
is geter
head
leg you combine the two motions as I
come in drrive if I stay up here with my
head this has to go really high
got it if I go down way low there's no
reason why I try to make that go high so
I combine in the
two make it
[Music]
this